hey Clinton Jones here with another
tutorial this is gonna be an advanced
muzzle flash tutorial or an advanced
gunshot scene now I know muzzle flash
tutorials have been done before you know
you guys know how to do them but I'm
here to tell you the most realistic way
to do a muzzle flash with added detail
we're gonna talk about the slide going
back we're going to talk about shell the
shell ejecting out we're gonna talk
about camera shake smoke and obviously
the flash here so I'm just here to take
it to the next level so let's get
started I have our footage in here this
one is with a machine gun and this one
is with a pistol so let's start with the
machine gun here what we're gonna wanna
do is go to where you start shooting
which is probably right here
let's drag in a muzzle flash from action
movie essentials - by the way which is a
must-have when it comes to action films
or anything else really it's just a
must-have it's great you can get it on
video copilot net alright so we're gonna
line up our shot here okay first things
first
not every gun shot has a muzzle flash
they're actually pretty rare so first
step in creating anything realistic when
it comes to gun shots is only have a
muzzle flash every eight to ten shots
that's very important because they're
very rare so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna save this one for the third
shot we'll move it down here so let's
get um let's get this guy here and we'll
line them up if you hold shift you can
scale it proportionally instead of all
funky like this scale it up line it up
we might need to rotate it just a little
now for this for the first and second
shots since I'm only shooting just
three shots here we are going to have
smoke so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna trim this clip to take off the
flash so let's go forward two frames and
then just slide that over and then bring
it back two more frames so you have
smoke let's go forward two more frames
and let's get another one in here now
like I've said before you want to look
at real footage of your gun being shot
if you want to stick to realistic now
there's a lot of things to check like
you know what slides back when when the
gun is shot the rate of fire just
different things like that so we'll trim
this down bring it up here and we'll set
the last one right here now these these
are the muzzle flashes are two frames
long so we're just going to trim it down
so it's one frame and we're gonna line
it up
you know this is my favorite one I'm
actually gonna bring in another one
now another thing sometimes you see like
the star-shaped muzzle flashes now those
only happen on guns where there's like
cuts right here well there's like little
slits and that's actually the fire
coming out of that slit and you usually
see that on an m16 or m4 s you would
never see it on a gun like this this is
an mp5 it doesn't have this little slit
so it's just coming out of this one hole
so keep that in mind as well all right
so let's lines up I'm actually gonna
let's see I'm actually going to I'll
leave that this little piece here scale
it down I'm gonna rotate it just a
little bit because the gun is angled up
and oh yeah that's right we need to trim
it down to one frame all right so we
have our muzzle flashes set up let me
you know what I'm gonna add one more
because it looks like a shoot for for a
little bit longer
it's really quick rotate it
and okay now one thing you want to do is
you want to set these muzzle flashes you
want to set them to additive mode that
way there they're a little brighter you
can seem a little better and one thing
with action-movie essentials these clips
are actually in slow motion a lot of
people don't change it there but they
just leave them in slow motion you need
to change it so we're gonna right click
and go to time enable time remapping and
you have these keyframes here this one
is the beginning of the clip and this
one is the end this one's back here
because remember we cut it so if you
bring this closer up the entire clip
will be played within those keyframes so
keep that in mind if it's all the way
out here you know it's gonna be really
slow because it's taking a long time to
get out to play so I'm gonna move it
maybe right here now let's do that for
all of these it just doesn't look right
if it's in slow motion
now the muzzle flash flash actually got
cut off there so I'll just put it back
on we're gonna fix this in a second
because it doesn't look too great okay
so we have the shot here and let's let's
fix this muzzle flash here it looks
pretty bad all right
let's take it off additive mode for now
and let's go to levels just type it in
the search bar over here drag it over
and bring the white up and let's do a
tint and tint it maybe 50% you don't
want it to be too orange some are orange
some are kind of whitish I'm making this
white so now if we set it to add it's
gonna be bring out really crazy you know
what you might want to try darkening it
no that looks like crap nevermind so
back to normal
all right so now let's talk about this
piece right here because on an mp5 which
this gun is on an mp5 this would be
sliding back ejecting a shell every shot
so there's a lever here I think you can
see it towards the beginning yeah right
right here this actually goes back and
forth kind of like a pistol wood it goes
back and forth every shot as well but we
can't see it so we don't have to worry
about it so let's talk about animating
this piece here okay
so I've never done this it's my first
time doing this so we'll see what comes
out okay let's get the machine gun
footage let's duplicate it and we'll set
it to just you know this is our first
shot here we'll set it to just that
frame by hitting alt and hitting
beginning the open bracket and close
racket so it just makes it that frame
and let's cut this out with a pen tool
and a little later we're going to model
a shell in cinema 4d and composite it in
to the shot so you just make sure
everything is nice and perfect gotta be
all about detail so the smallest thing
matters okay so we have that and it's
going to be opening right on this frame
so let's slide this well before we slide
that back let's hide it and let's create
a new solid let's make it black let's
bring it down here
and we'll we will set the opacity to 50
and we're going you know we don't have
to do that let's go here hit em copy our
masks here and then just set the opacity
back to 100 this is gonna be this is
gonna be like open you know it's open
here so let's feather it 0.5 you can
reveal the mask here let's set it to 1
because my camera is pretty crappy maybe
even 1.5 I'll be getting a new camera
soon just bear with me so let's see what
we'll do now is because on this shot
it's open so we'll set this black to
just that frame and if we go back if we
go here let's take this and we'll set it
we'll move it back where am i we will
move it no not that we'll move it back
like this and we'll give it some what we
get directional blur throw that on there
and get the angle all right maybe
something like that now I don't know if
you'll actually be able to yeah we're
gonna have to we're gonna have to um
let's see we're gonna make another mask
over top of everything so bring
duplicate it duplicate your footage
bring up here
let's go and just make a mask right
that way if we would actually get it on
the right frame that way if you know
when this thing shoots the the piece
moving is behind because it goes behind
the gun this is just one thing this is
one thing that you had just have to
check in the reference so
there you go
it looks pretty good maybe make this
mask maybe bring it forward a little bit
like there so you still have that shadow
right here
and let's give it some more directional
blur maybe like like 20 or something and
bring it like right there
that looks pretty sweet so yeah just do
that for all four shots and I'm gonna
pause it and I'll see you back in like
like one second alright so I finished
the other three little slide pieces here
I actually cheated and just duplicated
this first one and matched it up rotated
it and matched it up to fit with the
other with the other ones you know
there's nothing wrong with cheating as
long as it looks good in the end
but let's cheat a little more let's go
to layer new and make a new solid and
let's set it to a goldish kind of I
don't know kind of I don't know this
this color I guess I'm colorblind so
don't take my word on it but let's bring
it down this is a showcasing by the way
and let's bring it over here scale it
something like this
there you go let's actually mask it so
that um it actually looks half good when
it's coming out of here so
and just make sure that this kind of
matches up let's add a ramp to it and
set the start color to white and this
one to a kind of brownish yellow green
something I don't know well it looks
pretty bad hmm well let's go with it and
see what we so we come up with so we are
going to right about here is when it's
gonna start flying out of this piece
here so let's keyframe the position and
go forward maybe like four frames and
bring it over here
and then go on like maybe this frame
here and just bring it up a little bit
and give it some motion blur because
motion blur makes everything look good
and we'll see what this looks like that
doesn't look half bad
let's make some more okay let's
duplicate it and bring it over here and
we will turn off the motion blur so we
can see and set it up here this time
what we'll do is if you hit you you can
display all the keyframes here so let's
move it here and let's bring it let's
bring it up some more and let's move
this middle keyframe up some and do that
two more times just to kind of make it
look more more random tweak it up make
sure the colors are right mine's
probably way off because I'm colorblind
but yeah do two more and I'm gonna do
two more and I'll see you back in one
second all right so I finished up the
shells here I changed the color a little
bit you know I changed the direction I
made sure that the direction is random i
scale them down a little bit but the
most important thing is that they have
motion blur because that's going to sell
it now you could do a lighting effect
when this goes off you can kind of
brighten up the scene if you wanted to
or you can make an adjustment layer and
mask off with the pen tool you know here
maybe the arm maybe the knuckles and
this front grip here and you could just
brighten up those areas you know feather
them out a little bit and that would
give it a cool kind of lighting effect
but I'm not gonna do it just because
it's not too realistic you know I've
looked it up before and you don't really
see that only when it's at night or
maybe when it's a really overcast day or
something but it just it wouldn't be too
realistic for this shot um also you
might want to add a little bit of camera
shake not too much but just a little bit
because I remember the first time I
filmed someone shooting a gun with Brett
with my friend Brett I jumped like crazy
cuz it's been a while since I shot a gun
and I'm usually scared of loud noises so
keep that in mind and before we finish
up this tutorial I want to talk about
this pistol here I'm gonna do teach you
guys how to like animate the slide going
back
and just apply the same concept for the
smoke and the muzzle flash and the shell
for the pistol but let's go through and
talk about adding a slide on this let's
duplicate our footage and make it just
this frame let's mask out this top slide
piece now this is an airsoft gun and if
I were you guys I would buy some gas and
actually when you're when you're on set
and shooting a gun it's if it's a gas
blowback airsoft gun I would use that
because who has the time to you know do
all these slide things here so it's
gonna save you time okay now let's take
that and move it back like that and then
what we're gonna do is we need to cut
out you know this piece here and replace
it with just a barrel with a silver
barrel so what we're gonna do is you
know go to win like the gun is down and
you have this clean plate back here
so let's duplicate the footage again
make it that that frame and let's bring
it over here so we'll set the opacity to
50 and we're going to be cutting out the
area that we want so we want to cut out
maybe here we want to leave this
let me hear
all right and set it so you'd 100% and
you have your barrel here now that
doesn't look real at all so what we'll
do is go to layer new solid and make
that white all right and let's just
scale this down or you know what let's
just mask it since my barrel had to be
silver it's gonna be a little little
harder but not too bad
something like that set it back and
let's go to ramp add ramp to that and
we're going to match it up to this color
here so start color can be can start
here and color down here set it to white
and kind of a grayish color like this
and let's scale this down a bit turned
out that but the actual mask
all right so we have just oh yeah set
that into just a frame long so we just
have the blowback right here but now
it's missing some directional blur so
we'll add it to this just a little bit
for this piece here just to kind of
blend it in maybe like five or something
and then for the actual slide you're
going to want to add quite a bit so drag
that there
maybe something like that and if you
play that looks very realistic so just
add the smoke the muzzle flash and the
shell and you're good to go
that's the advanced muzzle flash
tutorial for you thank you